so we'll start uh
more embryonic again okay
so uh we're going to
start in yeah
okay
and then as i push forward you will take
a step back
and you'll come to uh
and as we do this here you want to uh
not give the open okay so you lifted
before i
did at that time so there's going to be
an ik adhesion
here at the sword contact okay and
that's what pushes you back
up so the first absorption is always
with the weight shift
feel the vibration in the weapon
better
initiative at this point okay so you
have to match
me
and then i do something tricky on my
side that he does not do
okay i'm going to take my back foot
and secretly move it in
so i'll just demonstrate that so it
looks like i'm stepping
one step forward but i'm i'm actually
going to
move the foot in so i'll demonstrate
that again
i'm going not here and keeping
this width i'm hiding that i change the
depth of my
stack so in and from here there's no
there's no other movement but the foot
will come in
you guys stay with me don't don't chase
the form chase the relationship
so you see from your point of view you
can't see i brought that footage
right all right okay a little
more detail so uh again there's not too
hard so the
all the way shifting you do in a count
stability you do here
so i don't want to move with my line of
gravity between my two legs
i'm never going like this so my weight
is going to shift i create a yawn phase
on the front leg then this leg has no
weight
and that's when it moves and then i'm
going to create the other young face
here and that's what allows that leg to
slip
in without it being detectable
in my body movement secondly
i'm trying to bait him i'm baiting him
with the risk
it's no different than any other baiting
strategy so
for example in the dilemmas or the
setups you use in network
uh you give the guy like a famed
guard past potential and you put him in
the triangle this kind of stuff
so you want to come up in a way
that it's enticing for him to feel that
the wrist is vulnerable
okay and that's not gonna happen
if the wrist is not the closest thing to
him
so if i start going like this it's
not my foot is closer okay so
i have to have this slight angle here
without having my needle pass
into a degenerated yarn face so that's
where i get
okay so as i move just my part
young face shift raise the sword
boom here thirdly
don't give a yin space opening
so you don't lift the sword like that
keep the tip out out out
out till you expose the new bait
no he he would have took that bait
already when
when the sword came in so he would feel
that disconnect
keep the sword out out out
out here so you see i slightly turn
reversing rolls
so same thing goes as he starts to move
i shift my weight go back
so i don't want to have mid-foot weight
he goes and i'm going like this
he moves i move he goes
oh his tip comes up
so you went young on your thrust so
just lift your tip up when you when you
go
lift your tip up that's it
then just as you're in your network the
guy has the mouth
or side control there's no reason to
give him
a perpendicular or or spine parallel in
in the mouth there's no reason to keep
the initial angle
so as he goes in other words i don't
want him to
move closer as i'm just here straight in
the same angle
or as he moves you'll see that he turns
so i have to turn
the fight rotates and this puts me off
the line
he goes don't step straight back
now you're over here and he's starting
to flank you
then just embryonic starting here
uh for proper cocu
internal aspects always mid-foot vector
and not the flat on your head if i if
you pay attention
if i just stand here with the flat of my
head eventually i'm going back
because i'm not midfield vector i'm heel
weighted
so i have to put the crown of my head as
the top part
not here then when i go into the
fake opening i actually will exaggerate
this with my gaze okay so we're going in
boom and i'm going to look down here
not here there's no opening if i'm
sitting here eyeballing him
so i'm over here looking this way
if we switch roles
perform as he goes my mets head
is at the upper chest not looking at his
sword
upper chest crown of the head high
not here
okay so i will use my mid scan
to add to the fame
he uses his med scanner
at my upper thoracic cavity
okay staying embryonic
we're doing all that
and he's gonna come in and put it
okay and sew it in the right place
and be at like an inch off okay
then embryonically i'm gonna do the cut
so this is not the technique but this is
the micro drilling of the technique
so i'm going to shift my weight rotate
my hips
move off the line
with the ushito tank so he's there
boom and i do the draw
we'll do it twice from there just to get
the reps in
then we'll start over
let's go back to that one move so
as i stepped in
this it looks at the upper part it looks
like your normal hidey miyagi
torso but it's not because my legs not
back
and my leg is actually not in alignment
with the hip you see here not here
here i'm going to put this here this
foot is now a detriment
to me trying to get around and off back
off the line i'm
faking the closing i'm faking
the detriment so as i move forward
oh here my hips will rotate but my foot
is coming
in and it's over here to the right of me
out to here here to the right of me
so that when i drive i get the
angle deviation in the rotation of the
weight shift
okay secondly
is he coming you go
so when i take the opening in the
embryonic phase
it's going to be here i'm not
already in my final cut
i'm here in a
he transition can i absorb
in my body okay not
in my shoulders here
my body feels
okay on the kidney tush
i want my body weight on the tip
be careful that you're not over here
like this
it's impossible to put weight here
so you see where the tip is that's where
my body lines up here
start over here my weight's actually
over here i'm tweaking the hell out of
my knee
this is not good
this is why this foot is very important
that foot determines where you where you
can and can't go
so the sword comes down and my weight is
on the tip
don't bring it back here weight goes
boom onto the tip
you